you don't need to take a trip to the
upside down to spot these spooky details
in the new stranger things trailer
freddy krueger hair metal in another
world here are the small details you
missed in the stranger things 4 volume 1
trailer
one thing it doesn't take long to notice
in the stranger things season 4 trailer
is how much older the main cast appears
in season 1 mike 11 will lucas and
dustin were all in the 11 to 13 range
and by season 3 most of them were about
14 years old season 3 debuted almost
three years ago at this point and the
actors playing the kids are all now
young adults by now the gang has
graduated from attending hawkins middle
school to hawkins high school or in 11
in will's case lenora hills high school
however not all of them have adjusted
well to the change in schools lucas
seems to be doing fine as a member of
the hawkins basketball team but 11 is
still something of a social outcast
while walking through the school halls
other students barely acknowledge her
though her friendship with will is still
strong still the terrors of high school
socialization will probably be the least
of her worries as shady government
organizations
and new threats from the upside down
rear their ugly heads
see on the other side
on the other side
though looking a little worse for wear
david harper's jim hopper is alive and
after somehow being transported to
russia after seemingly dying in the
season 3 finale the only question is how
eleven and her friends will get him back
thankfully the new trailer reveals that
rescue might come with the help of two
old friends that we're pretty sure have
no history of flying airplanes in one
frenetic clip joyce and hawkins
conspiracy theorist murray bauman
appeared layered up for winter weather
in a biplane going through some major
turbulence have they somehow tracked
hopper down and set off on their own to
rescue him from a russian gulag
stranger things wears its pop culture
influences on its sleeves and season 4
will once again honor the x-men in the
latest trailer mike wheeler and eddie
munson can be spotted wearing hellfire
club t-shirts which is a reference to
the fictional society in the x-men comic
books whose members have frequently
crossed paths with the heroes throughout
the years the easter egg may have a
deeper meaning than just a nod to the
x-men after all the hellfire club is
also the name of the premiere episode of
season 4. furthermore a previous trailer
hinted at what could be another group of
super powered children whether that was
a flashback to 11's time in the lab or
an indication that there's another group
of kids getting experimented on we'll
just have to wait and see either way if
season 4 follows up on this we may see
the return of 11 sister
kali
of course the x-men influence on
stranger things has been evident since
season 1. the very first chapter
features a moment where will and dustin
discuss uncanny x-men number 134 the
story that introduced jean grey's dark
phoenix persona 11's ark in the show has
drawn some comparisons to jean grey in
previous seasons considering that dark
phoenix emerges after a brush with the
hellfire club in x-men fans may want to
worry about how eleven and the hellfire
club of stranger things will intersect
max mayfield is featured front and
center in this brand new trailer for
stranger things introduced in season 2
max has a bit of a tomboy personality
and is known for enjoying video games
cars and skateboards early in the
trailer we see her talking at the grave
of her brother billy later in front of
the same grave we see max levitating
several feet above the ground as her
friends look on in absolute shock the
mechanism for her levitation is unknown
at this point but there is definitely
something supernatural going on it could
be some manifestation of her brother's
fatal possession in season three or
maybe max has inherited some kind of
power from the upside down either way it
definitely looks like max is in for a
wild ride one that could put her on even
footing with newfound telekinetic bestie
11. him and lucas are playing atari
right now but friends don't lie yeah
well boyfriends lie
all the time
toward the end of the action-packed
trailer there's a blink and you'll miss
it shot of horror icon robert englund
with a pretty intense look the star is
best known for playing freddy krueger in
wes craven's nightmare on elm street
franchise a supernatural killer who
stalks the dreams of his victims to
slaughter them in various inventive
grisly ways freddy quickly earned his
place in horror history thanks to his
unique design and it's clear that
stranger things creators the duffer
brothers are huge fans of the movies
there's nothing there
telling what's wrong
[Music]
don't stop it you're scared
england's brief appearance in the
trailer reveals the first proper look at
victor creel he's a patient at the
penhurst mental hospital who is
committed for murders he perpetrated
back in the 1960s he's clearly had a bad
time since then because aside from his
bedraggled appearance his eyes are
heavily scarred and it looks like he's
probably blind it's not clear if creel's
injuries are self-inflicted or if
they're the result of whatever seems to
be plaguing his ancestral home the creel
house either way it's great to see
anglin getting to play with a creepy new
character
near the end of the trailer comes a
dizzying sequence of quick cuts
including a few brief shots of a lone
electric guitarist playing atop a mobile
home trailer while red lightning flashes
in the background the long-haired
leather-clad musician appears to be
eddie munson one of several new
characters to be introduced in season 4.
the dim lighting and cold colors suggest
that he may be in the upside down and
there are heavy cables behind him that
don't appear to be necessary for guitar
amplification whether he figures into
the new season as a hero or a villain
there's no easy way to tell from the
trailer
since stranger things debuted the
hawkins av club has fought the
demogorgon the flayed and the hulking
mind player but they're about to meet a
terrifying new big bad who looks like
he's going to be more than a match for
11 in the game the trailer delivers its
first jump scare when a creepy monster
opens its eyes but it's not until the
end of the footage that we get a full
look at it the grey fleshy creature is
much more human than the demogorgon or
the mind player it's highly likely that
this unknown villain is the one
providing the narration at the beginning
and the end of the trailer especially
since its full reveal comes with the
intimidating line
laws
the creature's look is pretty gross as
it has no nose and its muscles are
stretched and warped across its entire
body there are also a number of
tentacles protruding out of its back and
it can clearly use them to move
considering season four is the beginning
of the end it wouldn't be surprising if
this new evil will stick around for
season five what this new monster has in
store for the kids of hawkins is unknown
we'll have to find out when stranger
things 4 volume 1 arrives on may 27th
when you say date
just so that we're crystal clear about
things so just
yeah stop talking i change my mind
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
stranger things are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]